well Clint Eastwood he casts off tape I
hope he casts off tape he casts me off
tape all right did you audition for
Clint or did you cast off tape uh no it
was for uh casting director and I I
actually auditioned for a different role
and then they're like same sort of thing
where they're like dude that you're
fantastic you're not we don't think
you're right for this but hey there's
this smaller role but it's actually
really powerful what movie uh letters of
regima right so there there's this role
that's like super cool and like it's
going to paint this terrible thing about
war and we think you could crush it
you're a marine yeah and and originally
I was going to have this like insane
dying death scene like you know again
it's someone looking like the whole
point was just showing how awful it is
and like you know some Kid Fresh Off The
Boat like barely out of high school you
know fighting for his life and it's this
really cool dying scene and uh I went
out there it first off it was the
craziest experience I went out in
Barstow and tried to find base camp and
there's thousand like you'd go over
these Rolling Hills to where where we
had to park and there's no information
and I'd come over the hill and they' be
like
300 soldiers Japanese soldiers they
don't speak English or they weren't
speaking English to me and I was trying
to figure out where I was dude it took
me like two hours to get to where I
needed to go and again it was so crazy
that like at base camp there was just no
information so it was a very weird
experience like it was really yeah it
was crazy and then they put me through
like a boot camp with like a real marine
and you know we're there with other
actors and some actors might look like
Marines but they have
zero you know they're just fumbling over
themselves they don't know how to hold a
gun or like you know when they're like
act like you're at War and crawl and
like you know there's a giant dude who
look but they went to boot camp no we're
in like a temporary boot camp it was
just like a you know they like a like
how you do things quickly yeah or like
to make it look legitimate and then and
and they asked me if I want to do it and
I was like heck yeah and thank God I I
can not I can look like you know I can
act like I'm a soldier because this guy
would ream other actors like I mean he
was just Relentless like real you no not
me he I never gotten that Crosshair
thank God but like I mean I saw like a a
giant man almost cry really oh yeah an
actor you know no I mean an actor I met
you know but yeah it was uh it was int
it was it was it was a it was a wild
experience and then all the stuff like
day one that we shot one scene and then
well wait a minute you're you're missing
when you worked with Clint the first
time you met Clint yeah I mean that was
one of my first scenes again did he say
anything to you like nice to see you
um I mean he was super nice uh he had a
lot going on he did I mean he had so one
of my favorite sto the first time I
actually met him was again I didn't know
where base camp was because it this
thing was massive right so we're we're
we're talking with like handlers I guess
like and like this Marine guy like
telling us what to do and just it was
such a simple scene my first scene we
were just running over Hill I had no
lines nothing just running over Hill uh
trying to escape for whatever I don't
even remember but so I run over this
hill and then there's this whole thing
behind me where uh bombs are going off
and like they you a couple Marines
capture a soldier or whatever but so I'm
one of the first over the hill and I and
come over this hill and it's base game
like oh here it is and Clen with's there
and right next to base camp is this like
it looks like wood that has been in the
sea for I mean it's a desert so it's
just been just crazy pile of wood and
he's poking a stick at it and I'm like
you know I went up to introduce myself
and he like without didn't he looked at
me but then he was like sh this thing is
crazy and I was like didn't know what he
was talking about he's poking the wood
and I thought he was like I was like the
wood and then finally this crazy looking
squirrel comes running out and that was
what he was doing and that was how I met
him at first it's crazy it's a crazy
squirrel and I was just dying laughing
and I was like this is the first time I
met him he's going to win awards for
this I bet and the first time I met him
he's like not paying attention to what's
going on at all now granted every time
after that he was and you know the next
time I ran over but it was just funny
the first time I met him it didn't even
look like he was watching what was going
on he was paying attention to the
squirrel I think there's something to
that